good morning nathan town involved in the
8 news now weather center with john
langler alex bacchus hector here on
traffic and
there's resorts world getting ready to
open later tonight las vegas boulevard
heck we're going to talk about the
traffic i'm going to talk about the sky
with sherry off today the official
temperature out of mccarran
hanging at 80 humidity between 20 and 30
percent
might feel muggy to you for folks from
other parts of the country that's
laughable but there is
juice in the air at 44 degrees on the
dew point we're 10 degrees cooler than
we were 24 hours ago
here is the latest radar with nothing
really showing up
they're going to be chances for widely
scattered thunderstorms again later
today we'll talk about that
from 80 right now we'll get you back up
to 85 in a couple of hours should be the
low 90s at noon some storms around that
will continue until three
with the afternoon high forecast at 97.
two days in a row under triple digits
here in mid to late june
hanging around 94 so your weather
headlines looking like this
thunderstorms are still possible one
more day under 100 and the heat returns
by the weekend